I've never had not one gay dream dude
really you're o for o on gay dreams I've
had gay fantasies not gay
dreams aspirations are different than
dreams gay goals different from dreams
all
[Music]
right so imagine you're an old man and
you're like 70 years old and you have uh
repeated dreams and those dreams are
there is gold buried under my house
there is gold buried under my house so
he starts to go hm I think there's gold
buried under my house and I think I need
to dig a big big big big big hole until
I find the goal mhm so that's exactly
what he
did unle he dug a hole so deep it's
disturbing it's like an obsession holy
sh
wa who how did he know it was like there
exactly he had
dreams heble to boore that that looks
like 20 ft or some [__] that's like
better than the cartel tunnels yeah so
he's he's digging right and he's like I
haven't found the gold yet but he found
some Jewish guy he found found a whole
Jew he found a synagogue a whole
synagogue he uh so he he digs this thing
130 ft
deep
130t dug it in the middle of his
kitchen uh and then wife loves him uh on
the 5th of January last Friday he's dead
after losing his balance while removing
water and mud from the shaft he slipped
and fell into the hole and died
wow and he never found gold
oh he was the gold all
along it's one of those stupid stories
or maybe he died he's wearing allce when
he fell
in now there's golden there what if it
was like on the other side and he was
just digging on the wrong side yeah
under the kitchen is it's in China oh my
god dude that's illegal to do right dig
a hole you can't dig a hole in your own
home in America I mean do you own the
land 130 ft below your house too I think
you own you got the land mineral rights
don't you holy I don't know [__] about
it I don't know [__] about it I think
yes I didn't know I didn't know I bought
mantle how about how about the air
rights I want some core baby air rights
you're going to want to pay EX for the
core trust me it's a good
core he also had his neighbors helping
him too he took it so seriously he
paying his neighbors to help this dude
was in a freaking neighborhood of crazy
people yeah what the hell no he's he I
think he was paying him he was so you
don't have to be crazy it's like you get
paid to like go down there and take out
the [__] ex if my neighbor was doing
a hole that big that looked like that I
kind of want to be a part of it a little
bit but then if the is not a
professional like in that field that's
dangerous for everyone involved what's
the field the Diggy guy okay I thought
you were going to say but he looked like
he had like scaffolding going down D
yeah yeah he is a had lights he had
lights yeah that's pretty crazy is it in
that photo is it going vertically down
all the way down holy [__] if you had a
neighbor that had that you would jump in
just because you can live by car you
want to do your own house I want to
check it out but if your neighbor like
[__] it I'll do I'll do it to your house
also if you like build a relationship
and like you're a part of the journey if
he [__] does find gold you
think you might be able to like be privy
to like 1% not if he paid if he paid me
right yeah but but then he's also old so
what if you you're next to not next to K
but you're only next to neighbor yeah
next to neighbor yeah I'm wondering why
he didn't do his whole
house yeah he focus on you just just one
little kitchen one little area do the
whole house and then go down just be
[__] falling everywhere dude he's got
to use the bathroom and stuff just lower
it every single level and then now your
house gets lower and lower and lower you
don't think that this guy was maybe just
crazy nope okay I wonder how long he was
down there before some I think he had a
mission and he was he felt a calling Hey
sirious though imagine if you got the
same Vivid dream repeatedly though
wouldn't you like think or do something
about I'm good at suppressing my dreams
okay here's the thing I'm probably
tripping I'm mention this before when I
found shut up Siri that's a dream all
right there was there was a time where I
was having a a recurring dream like and
it was very Vivid I always saw myself I
was at a [__] Li out and then I was
like sleeping on these bleachers and
stuff and then I rolled back and I like
fell right and that's when I would
always wake up from my dream and I'll
have this minimum twice a year W that's
a lot for many years right and then I
finally told my dad and I was like Dad I
keep having this weird dream and he's
like oh that happened to you when you
were a kid I was about to say that and I
was like what the [__] he's like yeah
when we went to go pick you up from from
Hawaii blah blah blah we were at a on
your last day there and then you roll
through you fell and that was the first
time we ever like rushed to the hospital
and you were fine blah blah blah right
and then after he confront or like I
confronted him with that dream and he
told me it happened I never had that
dream again yeah cuz you resolved that
me 100% so that's what I'm saying like a
ghost come yeah but imagine you get this
recurring Vision you can't get rid of it
unless there's some sort of resolution
his resolution was just him dying I
guess I mean if I was his homie I would
have just tossed some gold in
there hey look down there that's a real
homie that's a real hom do you see it
cuz I'm kind of in the belief that like
most of my dreams are [__] yep yeah
your dreams are
[__] don't aim for anything in life
you know what else [__] when you're
awake it's [__] too yeah no I feel
that uh believe the scientific ex ex X
Marx excavation the the scientific
disposition of what's the scientific
explanation for Dream It's just like
you're recategorizing shortterm
long-term memory or okay yeah like d Ram
in your eyes like I believe that 100%
that it sounds like cuz my dreams are
just a mishmash of like things that have
happened I guess or like experiences
right so it's like who gives it you're
just tapping out in your dream yeah yeah
just not getting away I had sex with the
man's butthole in a dream then let talk
about it was there connected to a man or
just just a man it was just a b
I've never had not one gay dream dude
really you're o for o on gay dreams I've
had gay fantasies not gay
dreams aspirations are different than
dreams gay goals different from dreams
all right wait so do you think having a
gay dream makes you a little gay it
makes you 100% gay I think if you don't
have a gay J you're gay Bart was the but
hole hairy I don't remember I just
remember going oh am I doing this oh get
me out of here let me just come and go
let me come and go so in the dream you
actually knew you didn't want to do it
yeah so you already you already warped
into doggy styling a man and you're like
why am I here that means you're not gay
that's a not drink but did you wake up
with a boner did you have morning wood
that day I don't remember you do yes you
do convenient he does I don't even like
anal sex dude you know what happened to
me one time I I had a dream I had a
friend like when I was in Community
College I had this one friend and then I
had a dream that I liked her in the
dream and then I woke up and I [__]
had a crush on her and I was like what
the [__] but then it didn't last long
though right it goes away no it's still
there I I had a crush on a girl in high
school too I miss you and then uh yeah I
had a crush on a girl in high school in
my dream first and we were having sex in
a tree and then I remember sitting in
class looking at her I'm going like did
you have the same dream
my but then I know that she imagine
asking her that he's he's like hey you
want to go visit this tree with he's
like hey you see that tree outside it's
kind of cool huh it's like What Dreams
May Come like you're just trying to make
her remember but then I don't want to
look at her too much cuz she think I'm
all weird and [__] yeah you don't want
her to think you're
weird damn dude well Dreams May Come
why'd you have to say that you brought
the whole [__] mood down
there that movie like Robin Williams in
that movie his character kills himself
and goes to heaven and then he does it
in real life and [__] oh [__] I didn't
mean connect that yeah yeah see that's
you can't be listening to a dream like
well that's kind of like Inception
right is
it doesn't kill anybody Leo's
wife yeah M remember she she thinks
she's still dreaming so she has to wake
herself up from the okay it does happen
to the wife yeah that's why you got to
stay out your dreams it's cuz her real
life was so boring [__] just be crazy
so I ignore that story but that's
like his wife his wife killed herself
and then he dies in a car accident yeah
and he wanted to go rescue her from hell
because she committed suicide okay not
quite the same all right my mood's
better my mood's better my mood's better
so there's still hell and suicide but
your mood's fine do you think if we
suggested gay dreams to you enough you
would have one I might yeah the closest
thing I had to a gay dream was remember
I told you jao wilnick was trying to
like holler at me and I was on his couch
and I was like hey bro that's a celeb
dream that's not a gay yeah yeah yeah
yeah different category that's a fanboy
dream he was trying to [__] me have that
and why would I think Jack would want to
[__] me well did you know the identity
of the guy in your
dream or was it just a butt he's afraid
to say he's blushing D he's afraid to
say he's like show it was NAD it was NAD
dude yeah was it n was it a big butt was
it a cute butt they were either Middle
Eastern or Indian or Mexican based off
Brown Butt based off the the color of
the butt and the hairs oh so Ry Brown
Butt Ryan or yeah it could be southeast
Asia is that why when I first met you
you were like you look familiar turn
around
that hey did you see that tree over
there it was a man's what do you think
of the tree what do you think of that
tree yeah I think all my dreams are
[__] [__] and I have crazy dreams
every night really there are always some
crazy [__] dude I don't dream that much
anymore yeah yeah or at least I don't
[__] remember I wake up and cuz you
accomplish bro [__] I live the dream
[__] go I live the dreams I don't
[__] dream at night that's what it's
all about that's a really funny thing
that I think a lot of people don't
realize they do um is that when you wake
up from a really interesting dream and
you start explaining it to somebody it's
not [__] interesting it's really bad
it's only real you cuz it's a feeling
it's a feeling when someone you you're
forcing your partner to listen to your
dream they're so [__] bored look at
you like I was in the car and I got out
of the car and then I went to the door
and I opened it and my mom was sitting
right there you just s like like and it
was crazy it's like an independent
movie there was water running out of a
sea [__] search light takes so long to
watch someone go get their mail and [__]
and like it's the worst they think
they're so artic
always yo that's what dreams are bro
holy [__] you just [__] independ it's
an so long it's a Fox Search light it's
a Fox Search light movie and then of
course you wake up and it was all a
dream it's great or like you you know
it's like you have sex with your uncle
and then you're like you got to go to
therapy every [__] independent movie
that sounds like a Blum housee film yeah
so have you guys ever found
gold
[Music]